okay so now let's go from talking about
police to talking about destruction of
property there are reasonable people who
have centered in on what seems to be a
dividing line as we see unrest and
protests and physical violence and
property damage around the country when
we talk about property damage there is
often a debate as to whether it counts
as violence in the sense of when people
say I am against violence
so most people agree attacking random
bystanders who aren't being violent is
unacceptable violence attacking random
police who aren't doing anything wrong
that is violence in the in any sense of
the word
most people agree blocking traffic is
not violence now you could be for or
against blocking traffic as a protest
tactic but most people would not say
blocking traffic is violence you could
maybe say well if you prevent people
from getting to work and then they lose
their jobs blocking traffic becomes kind
of like economic violence but in the
kind of violence we're talking about
blocking traffic
most people agree is is not violence
what about property damage so first of
all we have to call out the right-wing
hypocrites on this issue the concern
trolls who a month ago were saying
sacrifice grandma to coronavirus in
order to open the economy who are now
saying the worst thing you can do is
break the windows of a big-box store
they are hypocrites I'm not interested
in those hypocritical concern trolls I
want to deal with the real people with
the sensible people who in a real way
want to talk about this there are folks
who believe that for example destroying
government property when no one gets
physically hurt is okay but for example
destroying a private business is not
okay that depends on who you're
targeting you could be targeting a
business with bad practices or you could
be targeting a government that is a bad
actor or whatever you could find it you
know a logging company and say we are
going to destroy or disable their
bulldozers so that they cannot take down
these trees saying what determines
whether destruction of property is
violence is merely whether you're doing
it to a government property or to
private property
I don't think that's really the dividing
line what
this comes down to is what do we mean by
violence violence defined as behavior
involving physical force to hurt damage
or kill someone or something damaging
properties
sort of fits if you want to take a legal
perspective certainly the unlawful
exercise of force or the exhibition of
such force would encompass the
destruction of property now others would
say the real crux of human violence
versus physical violence against people
rather than objects is where we should
be focusing if you are talking about
breaking a window that's not really what
a lot of people believe is violence so
here's the bottom line if you want to
make this a semantic argument if you
want to make this about definitions you
can define violence in a way that does
or doesn't include property crime it
won't really get to the underlying issue
and the underlying issue is whether
sometimes violence is justified so even
if we agree on whether property crime is
or is not violence that doesn't answer
the question of whether property crime
destruction of property is a valid form
of protest who gets to decide what's in
the protesting playbook if you leave the
protesting playbook only to the elites
and those in positions of power it will
be restricted to only writing letters
you know chanting and holding signs
right the point is if you let those
already in power define what is okay in
terms of protesting certainly nothing
will ever change now is there any
guarantee that destroying property is
going to achieve change there's not we
do know that destruction of property has
been a part of protesting for a really
long time you look at the Boston Tea
Party destroyed property to fight back
against the capitalist monopoly and
political rights that were being claimed
by British colonists you look at slave
uprisings in the United States which
included destruction of property you
look at the plowshares aid a group of
eight Christians including priests and
nuns who took hammers to the nose cones
some nuclear warheads poured their blood
on the facility's papers and a call for
peace
so the legality part of it is clear this
stuff is illegal to do but I think we
can all every single one of us imagine a
situation where we do the moderate
methods and they bring no change they
don't get attention and then you say
well we don't want to do violence to
people but we're going to start
destroying some property destruction of
property in my mind is clearly violence
of a kind but in certain situations it
might be the only thing people have left
short of starting to actually do
violence to individuals now which
situations count I don't know I don't
know what about the consequences well
there are consequences you're not going
to get around that will property damage
get you what you want often it will not
property damage may in fact do the
opposite it may turn public opinion
against you but whether property damage
that's not hurting anyone physically is
a valid form of protest that's a
question that goes back at least
hundreds of years and anybody pretending
that there is one single solitary answer
that applies to every situation is just
wrong history tells us that's not the
case I want to hear from you about this
we're going to continue covering it on
the David Pakman show
Instagram at David Pakman show we will
take a break and be back with much more